hello everybody i see we have opened up
the doors and we are starting to have
people come in
i personally am uh
very excited for this talk which we will
get to in a very short order we have
people coming from all over the world
here
including our speaker who might be the
farthest away person attending
from around the world so we're going to
slowly get started
when we held this live the first thing
we always did was say who's hiring
and we did that and people stood up and
announced they had a job so they could
hire people well since that is not
feasible the way things are going with
the pandemic still
we are going to use the meetup slack
team to do that so
if you're not already a member of the
slack and you want to give someone a job
go to nyhackr.slack.com
and you can join our psych you might
actually need to go to different like um
actually nicole is there the link from
the webpage i just realized that you
might not be able to get in unless you
register when we have a registration
link we will post the registration link
in the chat momentarily you can go there
and there is a channel called job
postings and you can go there and
post jobs right that's simple go there
post a job you want to hire somebody um
people are posting all the time
um
me personally my company since i'm on
camera i get announced here uh i'm
hiring for many roles whether it is a
shiny developer a data scientist an
account executive a linux ad a linux
administrator
for roles i think they're all posted at
landalytics.com careers if not we have
been posting them in the jobs postings
on
ny hack r so check those out
as is tradition
we have pizza to start the meet up
this is a vodka slice with pesto sauce
drizzled over it from zazi's there's a
few of them popping up in the city and
you see some nice charring on the back
they use a gas oven so i don't expect
too much charring there's some good
cheese lock this slice is a little bit
old it's reheated but it's good
so zazzi's from new york that's aziz
well from all over the city there's one
on the lower east side one in the
village and there's a few others the
owner used to work at keste so you know
it's a good pedigree there so anyone
else who has gotten pizza let me know in
the chat let me know where you got your
pizza from i'd love to hear it
if you're not eating pizza my first
question is why my second question is
what are you eating let us all know in
the chat
and if you want to chat
go ahead and do it right here in this
chat window or on the slack the one
nicole just posted in the chat here we
have a channel called monthly meetup
chat go in there and talk about this
and speaking of chatting
since we're in this virtual world
we can't exactly all ask questions of
our speaker so throughout the meetup ask
questions either here in zoom
or
in the meetup monthly meetup chat and i
will collate them and at the end of the
talk i will ask the questions and get
them answered for you so please do
either in the zoom chat or in the slack
chat ask those questions
i see we've got some answers here david
got pepperoni mushroom from 46th street
pizza in san antonio and jeff has home
cooked flatbed pepperoni that sounds
interesting
greg has nothing your intermittent
fasting sure
randy you got a tasty section delisia on
the upper east side very cool
um amy also has pizza let us know before
we uh end the announcements because we'd
love to share this communal thing
while we wait to see what other pizza
people are eating
um
the videos from the new york r
conference last month are up
if you want to see videos from this past
conference or all the conferences you've
ever put on you can go to
rstats.ai there's a link on the top for
videos and you can see all the different
different
conferences we've ever put on thank you
nicole for posting that on there
and speaking of conferences we just had
the successful virtual new york r
conference so in december we are going
to have our fourth annual r in
government conference
we were hoping it would be
in person
but coveted still has us down so it will
be virtual as well
this is a conference usually held in
washington dc that focuses on federal
state local or international governments
ngos and other public sector entities
like health boards and schooling
and charities so it's our government and
public sector those tickets are on sale
at our stats dot ai slash gov and you
can use code ny hack r for 20 discount
as you can for just about anything we're
going to promote to you
so check that out there's a fourth year
we're doing this conference and we've
got a great lineup of really federal
state local and public sector nonprofit
uh speakers and we have about 10
speakers already lined up and we have a
bunch more we're just confirming that
we're going to announce in the next few
weeks
there are also workshops on december 8th
we have john hirsch who we all know and
love giving machine learning for public
policy workshop and alex bogosian giving
a talk about climate change data not a
talk sorry a full day workshop but how
to work with climate change data so
those should be really really
interesting
in addition to the upcoming conference
we have the next four months of meetups
scheduled we are super excited we're
this far in advance makes our life so
much easier
in november we have jd long at
seamastication on twitter giving a talk
about joining billions of rows together
in sql joins and r joins and pandas
joints
it's going to do some permutation of
those languages i forget exactly which
ones but november 18th jd long will be
giving a talk and we will be announcing
it in the newsletter soon
maybe even tomorrow or monday
then december 1st the week before the rn
government conference david robinson
will be giving the meet up talk and it
will be live coding a shiny app we all
know daveyrob loves being on the spot
doing live coding so december 1st come
check out drob live coding a shiny app
january the date to be determined we
don't have an exact date yet
but sometime in january i believe
mid-january we will confirm we have zj
talking about disk frame for those of
you that don't know disk frame is a out
of memory format for r that keeps your
data on a file on disk and allows you to
use d plier and data table on that data
set so that's coming in january
then in february we have hans talking
about duckdb
dot db is a really popular up and coming
database format that is could be both on
disk or in memory it can work with
parquet files uh it has bindings and
python r i believe rust go and other
languages it's going to be a really fun
talk they'll be february the exact date
to be determined
after february we don't know yet maybe
we'll be back in person in which case we
will live stream it just like we're
doing now maybe we'll still be virtual
it's good to see how the world goes
we're hoping that we're back in person
at some point next year hopefully
earlier in the year but
we'll see
so that's a lot of stuff we just had to
digest we had pizza we had jobs we had
meetups coming up we had video videos
from last month's conference we had our
government conference next week next in
two months and uh for anyone who wants
to see videos from the meetup you can go
to nyhakr.org
presentations.html and search through
the very clunky interface to find
slideshows and videos if you think that
interface is clunky and you don't like
it
change it i wrote it and it's not good
so please make a pull request it is a
publicly available repo github.com my
hacker slash my hacker make it better
it's not a high bar anything will be
better than what i built
so with that i hope everyone is excited
i personally am super excited for this
talk uh if i'm not using rstudio odds
are i'm using vs code just no way around
it it's the second most
open app on my computer r studios and vs
code always always the top two usually
open at the same time
today we're going to learn about how to
use r inside of vs code so you can do
all of your own work right in there
so everyone please welcome coming from
literally halfway around the world i
believe i have to get a measure to make
sure it's the right case but if not
literally almost exactly around around
the world please welcome [ __ ]
and i'm going to give you virtual
applause since then within the room
okay oh thank you for you thanks for
inviting me here and now i'm gonna share
my screen
can you see the screen
i can
okay okay uh thanks for inviting me here
my name is quinjan and today my topic is
using rmvs code
i'd like to briefly introduce myself a
little bit i'm a hedge fund researcher i
create research framework and tools and
do portfolio optimization high frequency
a lot of data analysis
i mostly use r for research and c plus
plus for efficient implementation of
algorithms and production systems
i'm a major collaborator of vs code r
and our language serve our language
server which is our today's topic i also
contribute to some other popular
packages such as data table and lintar
and some others
before we start talking about vs code
let's step back and take a closer look
at our studio actually it is our studio
server running on a remote linux machine
in this screenshot i i guess it should
be the environment most our users are
quite familiar with the user interface
of our studio is quite straightforward
you can see everything you need in one
screen the code editor the terminal the
global variables in the workspace and
the plots it's actually quite easy to
make things more difficult and it's
difficult to make things easy i think
our studio does an absolutely amazing
job to make data analysis much much
easier
basically our studio provides syntax
highlighting for numerous programming
languages
of course r and c plus plus some python
and nice code completion for r and some
basic completion for c plus plus it has
nice integration of r marked markdown
our notebook debugging linking for
version control provides some
very simple git support
i've been working with rmvs code for two
years but our studio is still the
standard we are looking at when we
consider the features and desired
behavior of how we should interact with
our nvs code the great things i
appreciate about our studio is that it
just works out of the box almost zero
configuration it's intuitive all in one
screen layout a nice integration of our
packages make our studio extremely user
friendly and easy to work with
it's quite important to notice the fact
that most our users are not professional
developers but researchers and those who
need to work with data the top concern
is probably whether the coding
environment makes them more productive
to solve their problems rather than how
powerful the tool is it is designed
through the lens of a data scientist
rather than a software engineer
however when my work gets more and more
complicated sometimes i find it painful
to use the free version of our studio
server in some scenario for example when
i need to work with multiple interactive
r sessions on one server to run two
scripts in the same projects
at the same time and view the output
side by side it is not easy if i need to
interactively run the script in another
project i have to switch to that project
but it also means i need to either save
or drop the workspace of the current
project when the workspace contains some
huge data frames it won't be feasible to
do so as it would take a lot of time to
save or restore the workspace
sometimes i need to work with multiple
programming languages some of my
projects contains
a lot of feature generating functions
such as some time series functions they
are implemented in c plus plus for
better performance but wrapped in our
functions for easier programming and
analysis with the existing data but in
my cases i have to work with r and c
plus plus side by side this the c plus
plus support in r studio it's a bit too
basic to be
productive
another case is that i might need to
write some html css and some javascript
when i work with shiny apps such as
live trading dashboard or something the
web development stack is a whole new
realm but they are just supported at a
very medium level in rstudio
sometimes i need to work with multiple
servers in one scenario
these servers are independent and
designed to perform different tasks but
all of them accumulate some data locally
if i need to analyze the data you know
on each server installing an r studio
server on each of them does not look
like the right solution another scenario
is that i use a
hpc cluster and i need to submit jobs to
the scheduler in this case it's not easy
to write the task script since the
cluster nodes that run the tasks do not
run our studio server
when the project gets larger it's
getting more and more difficult to
maintain without without more powerful
engineering tools it won't be easy to
search by symbol rename a symbol or find
references to a symbol
project-wise
another important thing in our studio is
that
the code editor and the r session are
somehow bundled when the our session is
busy the editor is usually not
responsive anymore when the oscillation
crashes due to some bug in the compiled
code the editor could not survive either
if there are unsafe changes there's a
risk that the cold might be lost this
usually happens when we do very heavy
parallel computing
but the worst case of all in some cases
that
the server cannot be
accessible through it could only be
accessible through ssh and sometimes the
rstudio server is simply not available
at all for network or security reasons
so i encountered all the above scenarios
in my work using r and i started trying
to use our nvs code two years ago before
that i've been using vs code to do some
c plus plus development for a few years
and the experience has been constantly
improved through time
vs code is a free open source code
editor the biggest difference between vs
code and rstudio is that vs code is not
specifically designed for certain
programming languages it has built in
support of the language server protocol
to enable code editing features such as
completion signature diagnostics cover
and go to definition and so on and the
debug adapter protocol to allow users to
interactively debug any program written
in any language as long as there is a
supported developer he also has built-in
support
of git and
tons of extensions to improve the editor
in different aspects
and vs code keeps evolving the support
of some of the most popular languages
are constantly improved they support
most of the features vs code has to
offer and the programming experience
with these languages is simply awesome
remote development and live
collaboration are two killer features of
vs code i'll talk about them later
according to a recent developer survey
by stack overflow vs code tops the
ranking of the favorite ides among all
listed editors including some
professional ides like visual studio
however the ranking here does not mean
that vs code is magically working well
with r in fact just two years ago
the the r support invest code was quite
basic only a small set of features were
implemented
from this screenshot it's easy to find
that vs code is more
focused on the code as the code editor
occupies major part of the screen
besides code editor are the file
explorer
and
document online and some little icons to
go to see the extensions do you see the
git
it's easy to compare different files or
compare compare different versions back
in time of the same file
it's a div
view the most exciting thing about vs
code is that
thousands of extensions are available in
the vs code marketplace you can use
whatever makes you more productive
so here is a simple screenshot of
working with r working with an our
project in vs code now we have a
dedicated workspace viewer help viewer
packaging package manager cloud viewer
and the reading console now the r
support in vs code has become much much
more powerful than one or two years ago
we are currently trying to make it
easier to get started with at the moment
we still need to install several
extensions and packages to get the full
experience first obviously you need to
install a vs code and you need to
install a few r packages such as
language server for code editing
features and http gd for the web-based
graphics device we recommend then you
might need to install a python and then
install reading console which is much
better than the official r terminal if
you need to debug some are called
inverse code you could also install the
r debugger which is a separate vs code
extension to have similar experience
with rstudio we need to install some
other extensions such as
path auto completion and some other
extensions
the radiant console is highly
recommended to work along with r in vs
code it supports syntax highlighting
auto completion and many other features
the author
randy ly started the r language server
our language server project in 2017
and it has been vastly improved in the
recent two years
the following is a series of
demonstrations of the code editing
features enabled by the the r language
server all the features are based on
static code analysis i'll explain what
they mean later let's take a look at
what language features are provided when
we edit our codes in vs code
i believe that completion is a very
important source of confidence when we
write codes in not only r but any
programming languages
the art language server provides all
sorts of completion while you type it
knows what symbols or functions you
define in your code it knows the
function arguments and their
documentation it knows
what the the objects defined in
building built-in functions and
objects provided by other packages
it also knows what symbols are available
in the scope of the position you are
typing here the different
variables starting with
v a r are all variables in the function
scope but do not but not outside
you can complete your
scope
symbols automatically
when you move the cursor to a symbol it
will
highlight all the symbols of the same
type in the document and the score bar
or minimap
so that it is much easier to know the
usage of such symbol
we'll click one and you can see
all the occurrences of this symbol
in the document
as you type in the r document the
diagnostics based on linter
is constantly running in the background
and mark your code with potential issues
if you install an extension called arrow
lens it would directly show the
diagnostics results in line with
different colors so the problems are
more visible in the code editor
you could also format the whole document
according to a standard the default
standard is the title style of course
you could
customize the formatting rules in your r
profile through language server
formatting options
we can also apply range formatting and
on-type formatting
when you type a new line or close
brackets you are trying to find the
proper code block to apply the
formatting
when you type a function call it will
show up a function signature including
the function name and its arguments the
documentation of the function appears in
below the signature
the hover feature is much leveraged to
provide more information as we move
around our corner if you move the
pointer to a function call it will show
the function documentation
if you hover on function argument you
will show the description of the
specific argument if you hover on a
symbol you define it it would just show
the line of code where it is defined
once you are not sure about where a
symbol comes from you just hover on it
and
it will immediately tell you the answer
go to definition works with functions
and symbols in the document
and the entire workspace if it is
defined in a file in your workspace then
it jumps straight to the right position
of that file if it is a built-in
function or defined in a package
it will create a temporary file and put
the function body in it
the
underlined path are are
recognized as document links to existing
files it's easy to tell which files
exist and which don't
if you often work with plots and need to
try different colors the color preview
and color picker should be should be
quite helpful here
simple navigation could help you move to
a symbol you want in the document or
across the entire workspace if you are
working with a big project or a package
with
many files or functions it will
definitely save you a lot of time
the symbol navigation also supports code
sections in plain our code and our
markdown documents
you can see the code sections in the
outline
you can clip click the item to jump to a
particular set code section
the code chunks and code sections could
be folded and unfolded to save space in
the editor
the find references feature is largely
based on go to definition when you try
to find references of a symbol let's say
x it finds all symbols of the same name
x across the entire workspace and finds
the definition of each x all symbols
that have the same definition as your x
will be treated as the references of the
same symbol it's extremely useful if you
want to evaluate the
impact where you need to refactor your
code and rename some of the symbols
across the entire workspace
the rename symbol feature is based on uh
references it
simply finds all the references of a
symbol and performance of performance
are renamed you can preview
the rename and you may refine refine it
as you like
call hierarchy is a more advanced
feature it is also based on references
you could follow the
incoming or outgoing hierarchy of a
function
another interesting feature is a
selection range you could expand or
shrink your selection based on ranges of
the nested expressions
all the code editing features introduced
above are implemented according to the
so-called language server protocol when
we open an our project in vs code the vs
code r extension starts
our language client which then starts a
language server and then we
when we open modify or close a document
type in the editor or move cursor or
pointer around the language client will
send many types of requests to the
language server the language server has
to keep track of the latest state of
each document do some parsing analysis
and respond to each request timely
the rsp the language server protocol is
an
abstraction layer between a specific
editor and a specific language if
there's no such protocol and the
developers of and if the developers of a
language of a language one wants to want
to support another editor they have to
write some new code to support that
editor in this case if we want all
editors to support all languages
then each pair of editor and language
will require some adaptive work which is
repetitive and obviously a waste of
resources with language server protocol
each language only needs to implement
its language server according to the
protocol and each editor only needs to
implement its language client according
to the same protocol then
the ad the language server of a certain
pro certain language could automatically
function across different editors
this mechanism is not just specific to
vs code but to any editor that supports
the language server protocol in fact the
r language server does not only work
with vs code but also work with adam
sublime text veeam and emacs if art
studio someday supports the language
server protocol it should immediately
work in a similar way too
now we have
implemented most
most types of requests defined in the
language server protocol
most of the language features
implemented in the language server is
based on a static code analysis the the
r parser parses the document and
generates an abstract syntax tree with
the type and text range of each element
in the tree we just analyze the tree and
extract the information according to the
request and the position of the cursor
for example if we detect a number of
library calls at the top level in the
document then we know that these
packages will be attached at runtime
then we then the completion should
should include
the
exported objects of these packages so
that's how we
populate the completion list
static analysis have some
clear advantages first we don't need to
run the user code to guess what symbols
should be there that when we actually
run the code
second the language server runs in the
background and could process requests in
parallel
it also means we don't need to we don't
need to start and interactive our
session therefore when the user session
is simply not started it's busy or if
it's even crashed the editor is still
functional and responsive
however using r is
not only about editing our code but also
working with our interactively that's a
big part of how our users use r
vs code r extension is the front end to
manage the interactivity between user
and our sessions it starts a language
client to communicate with the language
server he also provides some useful
commands such as create our terminal
send code to the terminal neat document
and so on
before our session watcher was
implemented in december 2019 vs code r
does not really talk to an our session
but simply sends some predefined
commands to terminal
the our session watcher provides a very
simple way to talk to an interactive r
session it is a
file based rather than socket-based
communication at the moment so that the
dependency could be minimal it is quite
stable both locally and under remote
development
it enables all features below from the
workspace viewer data viewer plot viewer
browser widget viewer and even supports
a lot of our studio add-ins
when a new our session is started in vs
code the session watcher will attach to
the news engine and show the process id
on the status bar item and the workspace
viewer and session symbol completion
hover will switch to this particular r
session if another session is created
the
the session watcher will switch to the
new session if you want to
attach to an old session just click the
button on the status bar
and the process id will be changed to
the old session
the workspace viewer is like the
environment pane in our studio it shows
the symbols in the global environment
the same information also appears in the
completion list and when you hover on a
symbol which is defined in the
current r session
here in the screenshot we define x and
we move our pointer to x it tells us the
the structure of x its type is length
and some sample values of x
thanks to the web view feature of vs
code we could put almost anything in a
webview as a
tab in the editor group
for example the view function is
replaced
by the session watcher so that it will
open up a tab to show the data in a data
grid you can reorder the columns or sort
filter and highlight the rows
if the the object being viewed is a it's
not a data frame or a matrix if it is a
list then it is displayed as a foldable
nested structure
by default the plot viewer uses a png
device each top level user input will
trigger the replay of graphics to a png
file
there are
but there are some
important limitations of such png cloud
viewer
there's no there's no history it does
not auto-resize resides with the tab it
only captures the last plot when
multiple plots are produced in a
top-level expression therefore i
strongly recommend httpgd as the plot
device
httpgd is an r package that
implements an asynchronous http server
graphics device for r it is based on svg
rendering so its
quality is very high it supports plot
history auto resize resize with a
tab you can open a plot in external
browser and save the plots to multiple
formats you can open as many
plot
as you like this code r also has native
support of httpgd graphics device so
that it is much easier to work with
inside vs code
besides the static graphics there are
also a number of packages that provides
interactive html widgets to be to be
shown in the viewer in our studio in vs
code they are
simply shown in a viewer tab you could
open as many viewer tabs as you like
here is a providing results done by the
provis package
also a shiny app is also
is shown in a tab you could also open it
in an external browser
besides all sorts of web views it is
amazing that we also support many r
studio add-ins by providing an emulation
layer of the r studio api package so you
get a very similar experience
as you use
the add-ins in our studio
the help viewer looks nice and it's
easy to use you could run a question
mark and a function name to open a help
page or you just right click on the
function name in the editor and open
help also you could open multiple help
viewers at the same time
or side by side
the
the r markdown is supported too in vs
code but it is still not comparable to
the rstudio features you can run chunks
and navigate between chunks
and we also support a live preview of
our markdown document it's been
supported very recently the live preview
supports syntax highlighting and
rendering math formulas
the demo here is actually recorded with
github co-pilot enabled looks like
somebody is guessing where you are going
to type in the document
actually it is
it is predicting what you are going to
type i'll talk about it later
when the document is
ready to render just click the preview
button
just click the preview button when the
document is saved the preview will
automatically update
you can see the github copilot is
constantly predicting where type
we are going to type in the editor
sometimes it is correct sometimes it's
not
suggesting what we like
and the document is rendered
side by side with
the original document
when the document is
saved and the live preview will be
updated too
the package management is handy
you can explore or search the packages
and their help topics or install and
remove packages with some fuzzy search
the multi-session support is quite
important to me personally in vs code
you could start multiple terminals in
the terminal pane and put them into
different use uses if you need
persistence then you might need a tmux
or a screen which
provides persistent windows and panes in
the terminal in each pen you can start
an r session or a htop monitor or simply
a wall simply watch a folder the
persistence is important if you want
everything to be kept in memory even if
your editor is closed or
killed or crushed
and with uh in this
screencast is uh
we can
we can
adjust the layout of the tmux window as
we want
we can put the the tool our sessions
side by side or in another tmux window
another vs code extension is our
debugger it provides an interactive
visual debugger you can set breakpoints
in the editor and launch a debugger
session whenever a breakpoint is hit
the session is paused you can look
around and see the local variables and
the call stack or simply hover on
symbols to view their values
as i mentioned in the beginning a big
proportion of the power of the vs code
comes from its great ecosystem where
many extensions are available
these are some some of the most used
extensions i personally find quite
useful
like for example like the
uh
vs code pdf you can view a pdf file
straight in
vs code tab
some features of vs code are not
specifically designed for a certain
language but could vastly benefit many
users in all fields
for example the real time collaboration
is one of them
two or more users could join the live
share session of a host the code editing
and running commands in terminal are
visible to all users
we also do some adaptation to support
the live share api so the plot viewer
data viewer and most other viewers
provided by vs code r are also visible
to other users
if you use c clubs c plus plus to write
efficient algorithms based on rcpp or
cpp11 to be
used in r then vs code can also provide
a fully functional development
environment for you to write z plus plus
with all the language features
immediately available
like auto completion go to definition
five references called formatting and
many many other features
with some configuration debugging the c
plus plus code in an r package
based on rcpp or cpp11 is also possible
and works nicely
so here is a demo where i'm debugging an
rcpp function with a gdv debugger as you
can see
the debugger is visual and interactive
you can run by step step into or step
out of the call stack and see
the local variables
and inspect the call stack easily
it's just running a
test that
test
which
calls
the rsvp code internally
when the breakpoint is hit
then it's
you have the total control of the
workflow
if you look carefully
of the
screencast i just demonstrated the rcpp
debugging is actually running on a
remote machine
in
may 2019 microsoft released the remote
development extensions for vs code it
supports connecting to a server via
ssh windows subsystem for linux and
docker containers so programming on a
remote machine is made just like
programming locally and your and your
favorite extensions just works out of
the box on the remote server
so as long as you have ssh
access to a server you can
use the remote development
extensions to work on the server just
like work locally
if you use
if you use some darker containers you
can just attach to
to the
darker
darker containers
easily
a very recent news about vs code is
the github copilot just like i have
mentioned earlier it provides a vs code
extension to help you write code in any
programming language as far as i know it
is trained by the public code hosted on
github i've been using it for
for several months and it is amazing we
are writing some code that is commonly
used or follow a certain pattern
you just check whether the copilot
suggests the desired result and press
tab if you accept the suggestion from
all the above examples we can clearly
see that our users could not only
benefit from the evolution of the
our community but also enjoy
the amazing new tools provided by the vs
code ecosystem
if you like
if you would like to try the github
co-pilot it's quite interesting you can
sign up for a technical preview and then
you you are
you're going to receive some emails from
github and you can you can try it in vs
code
so that's the talk today we i put the
links of the
language server that's called r and the
debugger projects on github so if you
would like to try them you can just
install github and start trying
great thank you very much i'm going to
give you a virtual round of applause
because again nobody here we got some
clap emojis in the chat that'd be great
oh thank you
and i see one more question i'm going to
write down
uh they're
running resources for
okay so i want to make sure i have all
the questions written down in case i'm
in here uh unfortunately zoom doesn't
let me copy and paste the question so i
need to transcribe whatever questions
are asked
okay look at all those clap emojis
people love this talk
we have multiple emotions
yeah oh you probably can't see the chat
window people are loving this so i will
say for everyone thank you very much for
that wonderful talk and we have a few
questions for you
all right uh first up um not so much
about r but you said something about
there's an extension for showing code
errors in line
um yeah
what's that
it's called the arrow lens
cool yeah
all right oh look at that some nice good
i mean hart [ __ ] that's cute
look at all these emojis people are very
happy with this talk i think people are
really excited
thank you so much
now you've seen a lot of uh people on
twitter talking more and more about vs
code of r so that's that's pretty
exciting
um a question that just came in we'll do
this one before other ones because i
can't copy and paste um is there any
support similar to features for building
packages in our studio where you could
clean rebuild test the package um is
there anything like that for vs code
yeah we currently have
some built-in commands from the detours
package just like install
a clean or a load or something they're
simply
some of the commands are simply
sending pre-defined commands to the
terminal
so it's um it's not a very hard thing to
do
yeah so a lot of the shortcuts in our
studio are just calling our code with
keyboard shortcuts
this one is not a question but rather a
statement and it says thank you for all
your contributions in making this so
easy
oh thank you
actually i think it's not so easy at the
moment because
the hardest thing
at moment is that
it is not
it's not easy for beginners to get
started in vs code to use r because we
have to do some configuration to install
a bunch of packages our packages and vs
code extensions
if you use our studio you just you just
open our studio and everything just
already there
so i think we have to do some work to
make it easier for beginners
like is there a like a and vs code like
a meta extension we can install one
extension that installs a bunch of other
extensions
yes that is called the extension pack
wow right there we can do it yes we can
do it at multiple levels one is that we
can create an extension pack which
which depends on a number of extensions
we like
another
another way is to is that we can define
a
darker image which contains and a full
experience of our
development environment in envs code and
they are they both exist i think
yeah great
those are that seems really helpful
um
so how do you handle i guess i saw when
you were in the terminal you had to
launch r manually in the terminal um a
how do you handle multiple versions of r
just have to be careful which one you
launch or is there and how do you
determine which one gets the arguments
when you need a team x going in two r
sessions how do you know which one gets
the command
uh in a teamwork if you use a t-max and
you will highlight the active paint
so you have to distinguish which which
one is active yourself
you can make it more clear by
defining its style
to show which one is active
but well but for
different versions you could
obviously if you have different versions
of r installed in your machine
they must be on different paths so
you can start you can start your r
sessions manually with the different
executables on the machine and
and
and if it works properly it could attack
it could automatically attach to the
active session
when you click the status bar item you
will not um
really care about which version of art
you use
so whichever one's open in your terminal
we'll just use that one
yeah
all right
and there's a setting in the settings
for vs code to set which is the the
default um version of our correct
actually if you
okay of course of course you have to
install a certain version of r but uh
any version you like just meet the
minimum requirement of the vs coder
extension okay
cool
um
when you showed the viewer the you know
using the view function you know in our
studio it paginates if you have large
data it doesn't do it all at once
how do you handle large data frames in
the viewer
yeah actually it's a very good question
and we have
we have a bunch of issues
talking about this actually
currently we just
write all the data being viewed on on
on a json file and put it into a a data
grid to be shown in the webview but
if the data is too large and
it costs a lot of time to write that
data because the the
[Music]
because we have to write the data and
the vs code r has to load the data and
it's it could be time consuming when the
data is big
but uh our studio does an amazing job to
to support the asynchronous
loading of the data if you scroll down
to
to more lines more rows you can load it
dynamically
but
this mechanism relies on a two-way
communication between your editor or
your viewer and the r section currently
we just our session watcher
just implement a very
simple file-based communication
mechanism it's uh it's even not a very
robust two-way communication it's simply
a
something like a one-way communication
is when user input something we just use
the task callback to capture the uh
the result of the user input and then we
design
how to present the result inside vs code
and it's a one-time evaluation of the
results so
if we are going to support the dynamic
loading of the data in the viewer we
have to implement some kind of socket
communication to uh to let vs code r and
the r session uh talk in two in two-way
talk
okay that's probably a big a big task
i'm guessing
yeah i i think it's uh it could be
useful in this sense
cool yeah i think that would be like
people have like a million road data
frame you don't want to see realize that
yeah
cool um
someone has a question about
how suitable is vs code for our markdown
workflow so a lot of people use r
studios like you have our markdown
you're rendering repeatedly and you did
say um it's
not quite all the way there so how
suitable would you say it is
actually i'm not a very heavy user of
our markdown and
uh basically
vs code r just
has some very basic implementation or
support for the our markdown uh our
markdown tools and in our studio you can
see it is very handy you can you can
present the results just in line just
beside just below the code trunk and
you can easily
insert a chunk navigate between chunks
and evaluate the code and you can create
a new
markdown document from a predefined
template from some packages and
these parts
from creating documents from packages
are
completely missing at the moment in vs
code and
something like our notebook is not yet
implemented in vs code 2. so
currently we just have very basic
some code trunk navigation and live
rendering of our markdown
just very basic features for that but in
the future i think we can
do a lot more if there are uh much more
demand on on this
and it suddenly mentioned the notebook
inline rendering i'd say
most most users of our markdown don't
use that feature that's more like a
jupiter notebook they would use our
markdown control shift k and render the
whole thing each time so i think you're
probably not that far behind from our
studio experience if you take away the
notebook feature which i'm not sure how
much usage it gets yes if if the usage
is so simple like that we already
supported it
wonderful all right there's that answer
um
similar to our markdown how about uh
rendering and viewing shiny apps and
exposing plumber
apis
i think that the current support
is the the
is exactly the same
uh same as
you do you start
uh you use it in a plane or terminal
we don't have a particular support in
the editor aspect
so if someone is writing shiny code and
they um they assume they they create a
keyboard shortcut it calls run app uh
does it pop up in a pane would it pop up
in a browser window would you have to
actually go manually enter open in a
browser
yeah you can find any key bindings to uh
to any command you like to send to the
terminal to start a
shiny app or something
okay how do they get to the shiny up
once it started this is the main
question
okay it's just uh when you're starting
shiny habits uh
a new web view will be created and it
will be automatically revealed in your
editor
oh wait so the shiny app would be seen
in vs code
yes of course it's in vs code that's
really now you can you can open it in
external browser
if you like
that's
very similar studio great
um this is a
question from me um you talked about
using team up to persist sessions
you know our studio server that's a
feature persists sessions automatically
is that anywhere on the roadmap to
persist sessions automatically so we
don't need to use tmux
no i i don't quite understand the
question
oh um in our studio server if you close
down your browser uh when you reopen it
yeah it
restores where you left off
yeah and you right now you can do that
with tmux is it on the road map to
have that done automatically so i don't
need to run tmux it just sort of saves
my r session somewhere
oh yes uh actually we don't have a
roadmap for that because
it sounds like a rework of the same
thing of tmx
well i guess actually you can use a
debug or screen or anything i think you
like for just for persistence because it
is uh
i think it's um it might be
it it is a needed feature for many other
users but if they're not very familiar
with
the linux commands or
how to install such things or start such
such things or customize the tmox
i think it's not very easy to begin with
i think we have to do uh
some work to make it easier but
i
i have no idea at the moment how to make
persistence much easier
yeah at the moment
tmux i agree tmux is you know could be a
daunting starting point for a lot of new
users so even experience
could be daunting
yes
um you showed how to you know move pains
around and everything just sort of drag
and drop the pains is there a way to
have it start with four panes like code
terminal plots and help just in the
beginning yes i i think vs code has
in some prior release it has
i think it has some a pretty user user
could customize the default layout of
the vs called window i think it exists
but i'm not sure at the moment
and the real question is can you do that
for um
like for r i want four panes but for c
plus i just want the code and for
another language that might be asking
too much of vs code
i think it's possible too because uh
but i'm not sure uh you can customize i
think you can customize the layout
uh for each workspace or
or something or globally something but
i'm not sure about that
i can check it out later all right
um and similar there's another editor
question
our studio has a feature where you could
pop up like a code editor into like
another window so you could put on a
different monitor can you do that with
vs code rip one of the
code tabs out and put it on a different
monitor
i think uh it is not supported at the
moment
okay
cool that's a i know that's obviously an
editor thing not at you thing
um
one question just came in i'll get back
to our other questions because i see it
in there and i had to grab it before it
leaves um is it possible to set up a
global linter configuration
yes of course in the
github page
in the readme of minter package it
shows that if you put a dot linter file
to the to your
user home
home folder it is a global inter
configuration and it can be it could be
put on in
each
of your project if you like
yeah there you go perfect that was easy
um this is not about vs code but about
the language server um do you have do
you know of an authoritative reference
for setting up the language server
lsp i forgot the piece stands for
language server protocol
um for
emacs yes i
e-max has
has an implementation of rsp e-max rsp
or something it supports
at some level
some uh most of most of the asp features
are supported i think but
but in some very tiny aspects it may
behave
slightly different from other editors
which due to the
technical details of their
implementation of the language client
but uh but it actually works
but our language server actually works
with it's called adam and sublime text
vm emacs just as as i mentioned in the
slides
all right
um
this one's not about r but um you
mentioned docker extension in there and
there's a question about
every time you run docker on you use the
you know the uh
the command pallet to run docker does it
spawn neutral each time or can it
just work in an existing terminal
i don't think he could uh you could
reuse uh existing terminal you just
start actually it starts a new uh
a new vs called window
okay
and then related there's a question
do you have any do you know of any
resources for using r inside docker you
mentioned uh using
the remote capabilities of vs code
inside docker so if you're wondering do
you have any resources for getting
started there setting it up
actually i'm not a very frequent user of
r in docker uh just um do some
search i know some uh like the our
podcast
the author just uses are in docker very
frequently and in vs code
just like the environment we described
for some
from some reproducible research and
reproducible development something like
that
cool
all right that is all the questions i
collated so let's give everyone a minute
to see if there's any last minute
questions there's often one person who
sneaks in a question right at the end so
give everyone a minute to
um to see if there's another question
while we wait for people i'll say that
we will have this video up on uh ny
hackard.org and on which is essentially
just a link to youtube by the way um in
a few days we'll also try to get the
slides posted at ny hack r uh how did
you make the slides what did you use
that's a question for me
nice lies
are your sides
okay i i just made my my my slides in
powerpoint because it's quick
fair enough yeah i'm a big user of like
i o slides and sharing but like
sometimes just powerpoint is quick and
easy yep yeah yeah and just so everyone
has some uh context here
i asked kuhn to speak maybe three weeks
ago right so this is very short notice
he pulled all this together so a double
like applause for like hey this talk was
he did this on three weeks notice so to
give everyone like another little emoji
clap for being short noticed pulling
this together in maybe less than three
weeks so
thank you for yes
uh it's really a pleasure for me
thank you thank you um i certainly
enjoyed it um as i said earlier this is
my second favorite editor so i'm excited
to use it more for my favorite language
uh r is definitely my favorite language
i'm excited to use it a lot more for
that oh one question for me um
do you have you seen any stand support
in vs co dan goes so well of r
uh
i'm not sure if there's a particular
supporting vs code i'm sure that it
could
it could uh probably work as expected
invest code
yeah i think so just needs to have some
way to do the lending which i guess is
in our package and there's another
question for randy so um he uses the
remote dev extension to get to a pbs
node remotely he has to log into a
submission node then q sub
from
and then from there he has to get to a
compute node how do i get vs code r to
work in this setup i don't know what
you're saying andy um do you know can
you see the question in the chat window
yes of course uh actually it is uh
uh it is a question asked in the issues
on github on
for vs code uh vs code r and
uh actually uh the
the session watcher
is based on a file
on the file
file based communication mechanism and
if your
compute node
does if we if the the r extension cannot
access the compute node
um the its file system then we can't let
the session watcher to attach to the to
an interactive session started on the
compute node but
but it does not mean that we can
we can do nothing about it
actually uh
we can the simplest thing we can do is
that we just
somehow start start and our session on
the compute node manually in the vs code
terminal but the session watcher is not
attached and we keep the code
in
in the on a remote machine that we have
access to well ssh and the language
server should work because it does not
rely on uh live
our session
or the interactive r session the the
code editing features are to be there
but
the
interactivity like
central water said session watcher
features might not be available on this
setup
cool so
i know for me i was a little lost by the
q sub and pbs hopefully that meant a lot
to andy and anyone else listening um and
your answer triggered another question
from me um your static file um i forget
the word even you say your static file
interpreter static file analysis does
the code file have to be saved for it to
work or if i'm like working in a file
working work and haven't saved my file
for a while and i define a function will
you see that function
okay you don't need to save the file
because uh the
when you
we open a file save a file or even
modify a file the
the language client will send all its
content through a language server
protocol request to the language server
so as you type in the document we
already know the whole content of the
file so then we can do the parsing and
everything else to fulfill the request
okay then the follow-up for me um
if i put oxygen documentation like above
the function using a you know hash
single quote at param that stuff do you
pick that up and can you make a help
file like a help file for my defined
function as i type it
actually uh we captured the
the oxygen comments in the hover but i
didn't show it in the slides if you
write a
write some oxygen
uh ruxin comments above a function if
you hover on the function then you will
show the documentation just like a
standard documentation
and can you make that show up in like
the help window in a pane or is that too
much
actually at the moment we don't have we
don't have that support at the moment
still pretty cool you get the oxygen
real time that's awesome
all right i'm impressed by that by a lot
of the stuff i'm very impressed by a lot
of the stuff i showed
all right so since i think everyone's
had time to
ask their questions it's going to very
quickly remind everyone if you're
looking for a job go to the job postings
channel on slack if you're looking for
pizza i already ate all mine but you
know email me if you want a pizza wreck
i got lots mostly in new york city but
some other cities too
videos from the new york r conference
were posted at rstats.ai
the rn government and public sector
conference is december 8th through 10th
uh go to rstats.ai gov and use discount
code ny hack r
um november will be jd long december
will be david robinson um so jd will be
talking about giant joins in sql and r
maybe python i'm not sure d rob david
robinson will be live coding shiny app
zj will be talking about disk frame and
hans will be talking about duckdb so we
have a conference and like four more
meetups planned already so we have a lot
going we have the wheels turning on a
lot of the stuff
um
as we go by i'll send more notifications
to everybody let you know uh follow my
hacker on twitter and we'll keep
everyone really informed so i just want
to say thank you very much once again to
coin i really really really enjoyed that
and i hope everyone else did too and i'm
going to go practice this stuff i'm
going to go use vs code r um tonight so
everyone one more time as we head out
thank you very much oh thank you thank
you it's a pleasure if you guys have any
questions you can just raise new issues
or discussions on github
yes please go to the github github's a
great place i love raising issues on
github in a constructive manner and
helping people and asking questions and
helping with features and reporting bugs
and
uh interacting with people on their
github issues really show in a nice way
really shows that you care about their
work and people love it when you care
about their work so go to get up and uh
and let go know how much you're using
software
yes
all right great so everyone with that
enjoy the rest of your night or dan
o'coon it's very early in the morning
for you so thank you for being here so
early and everyone else around the world
whatever time zone you're on or in
america or elsewhere
go have a great great day slash nights
this afternoon bye everybody
all right bye bye